what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here today I am going
to do a first time watching for the film
Planes Trains and Automobiles I've had
this on my list for a while and I was
trying to find the comment but I
couldn't find it but someone was like
thanksgiving's coming up you should do
Planes Trains and Automobiles and I was
like oh is it a Thanksgiving I I don't
know anything about this movie other
than John Candy and Steve Martin are in
it other than that no idea what I'm
walking into right now but it's a 1987
comedy I'm sure it's funny ladies and
Gentlemen please go ahead leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated also
subscribe and click that notification
Bell get notified when we got a reaction
up on the channel That might be of your
interest also full-length Reaction watch
along as we single with your own copy
for playing trades and Automobiles
available for super sexy rejects on our
patreon page we also cover exclusively
over there several shows of reaction
highlights and watch alongs included
your support has been astronomical thank
you very much ladies and Gentlemen let's
get into it
[Music]
really set in the stage here
oh my God I'd be so annoyed following
Cosmetics not curing cancer why don't
you wait and go out with me on the eight
you're never going to get a cab at this
hour I told Susan I'd be home by nine
have a good holiday
I'll see in Chicago John you will never
make this city
[Applause]
[Music]
a day of rushing will always be a
relatable subject literally have to go
to a birthday dinner like moments after
filming this and pick up something from
the airport ironically
Kevin Bacon from Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special
foreign
yikes
[Laughter]
was this before or after Kevin Bacon was
famous
could I offer you ten dollars for it huh
twenty I'll give you twenty dollars for
it let's say 50. anyone who'd pay fifty
dollars for a cab
certainly pay 75. oh what a dick have a
happy holiday
this will help
what
all right
[Applause]
God
this compounding stress in less than 10
minutes I feel like I'm watching a safty
Brothers movie they did good times and
uncut gems in case you don't know
oh my God
he's hiding
hahaha
I had no idea that was your cab
let me make it up to you somehow huh
please I have first class ticket you
have a coach seat assignment
hi Larry hi Liz
God I I feel so stressful
first you delay me then you bought me I
can't wait to see what happens next is
this a coincidence or what Del Griffith
I sell shower curtain rings
best in the world I really like to
finish this article a friend of mine
wrote it so don't let me stand in your
way please don't let me stand in your
way the last thing I want to be
remembered as is an annoying
blabbermouth
you catch me running off of the mouth
just give me a poking at chops
you're Griffin inspired by John Candy
oh that feels good oh God I'm telling
you
my dogs are barking today
oh God what are you doing man that feels
better
no oh that is disgusting
[Laughter]
where are you I'm in Wichita we couldn't
land in Chicago
what's going on Neil
what's going on is I'm in Wichita we
took off from New York they closed
Chicago and landed here
she's suspicious of him
you know the finest line a man will walk
is between successive work and success
at home I got a motto like your work
love your wife
well I'll remember that that's a nice
motto
it's the flight situation simple
there's no way on Earth we're gonna get
out of here tonight trains
uh if you want to pick up the cab fare
I'll make sure you get a room for the
night
yeah I'm sure great all right grab it
into this thing will you
is this your trunk yeah you should try
Logan this thing around New York City
Jesus Christ
a friend had never been around here so I
just figured he'd like to look around
the middle of the night I know I
know I'm out of this town
you know that's a damn rare thing these
days
the ultimate Optimist in the ultimate
pessimist
colliding
yeah well I'll have a charger for a
double but with a discount will come out
even well there you go that's pretty
good we're saving money already we're a
pretty good team the storm brought us
here I know all about it last room in
the complex
I mean share
yeah it's a double
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you want to take a shower no
no I meant if you want to go first
but what do you think I am
that's funny that's funny like how
there's a bit of a dark comedy Edge to
this
[Music]
damn Steve Martin you a hairy man
[Music]
so annoying
God
I love capture this from his perspective
see I had no idea
[Music]
um
why why that's it well go ahead sleep in
the lobby see if I care I hope you wake
up so stiff you can't even move you got
a free cab you got a free room
and someone who'll listen to your boring
stories
ouch
you're playing when you started talking
eventually I started reading a vomit bag
you're a miracle you're stories have
none of that
they're not even amusing accidentally oh
this is so mean I I could tolerate any
any insurance seminar that say how can
you stand it and I'd say because I've
been with Daryl Griffith
I talk too much
I also listen too much
I could be a cold-hearted cynic like you
and I don't like to hurt people's
feelings well you think what you want
about me I'm not changing
I like I like me
oh my wife likes me
my customers like me
because I'm the real article
what you see is what you get
he means well
should at least say you're sorry
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
holding his hand
why did you kiss my ear why are you
holding my hand
where's your other hand
between two pillows
those dark pillows
oh
[Music]
God you're making me feel like a
freeloader
get me on the train we're Square
you got it
that's the easy part
oh no
I had over 700 on here seven hundred
dollars
there's 263 dollars in there there's a
dollar more then you can call me a thief
counted 263 right we were robbed
do you think so
just get me to the train station and
I'll take care of everything else oh I
got that all covered Gus's son's gonna
pick us up
of course
nice flannel
oh oh my god oh
what's his name I know that actor I
usually know his name
Dr Connors wrote a Perdition what is his
name
it's really gonna bug me that I don't
know
how are you
just Neil Page from Chicago hi
good to meet you both
mm-hmm
the health
I'm to drive you to Wichita to catch a
train yeah we'd appreciate it train
don't run out of Wichita
unless and you're a hog or a cattle
[Laughter]
what the
get your lazy behind out here and put
that trunk up in the back she's short
and skinny but she's strong
her first baby
come out sideways
she didn't scream or nothing
no more than 45 though
depending on which way he goes if he
calls the back roads it could be
anywhere up to 70 miles oh well it
actually got me damn
they didn't have two together you've got
to be kidding me I need your address I
gotta send you the money to pay you back
for the sticking it's a gift happy
holidays
same to you
this is not the last they'll be seeing
of each other
this is like a semi horror movie going
home for Thanksgiving me too I'm just
gonna make it
nope it's a misleading midpoint of the
film
[Applause]
holy God
I would uh I I I'd just lose my [ __ ] so
much sooner than him
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
sad part is I'm more like Steve Martin
and then I would be John Candy you know
[Music]
thank you
oh wow wow wow
[Laughter]
I guess this is probably as good a time
as any tell you this our tickets are
only good to St Louis
St Louis the Shinedown is tighter at the
top thumbs ass look it's Thanksgiving
[Laughter]
that's great
who wants to sing a tune who's got a
song three coins and a fountain
each one seeking happiness
Flintstones meet The Flintstones
and he tried thank you they are filled
with helium so they're very light
thank you this is an autographed Daryl
strawberry hearing
all right those are very special
earrings by the way damn
he is hustling
I've been spending too much time away
from home I've been home in years
no I really think we'll get to where
we're going a lot faster if uh
we were all alone oh what
oh no yeah
make the money buy your kids
I don't want the money okay
then leave it if you want to leave it
fine that's okay I I'm done okay I've
got to get going now so if you look he's
so sensitive damn I feel so bad
John Candy has such a
sincerity and sweetness to him
[Music]
oh my God the monster's about to be
Unleashed
hahaha
oh actually that's pretty dangerous oh
come on
oh boy he looks so bad
[Laughter]
welcome to Marathon may I help you
yes
you can start by wiping that [ __ ]
dumbass smile off your Rosie
cheeks
[Laughter]
oh my God that's enough Toyota Mustang a
[ __ ] Buick four [ __ ] wheels and a
seat
I really don't care for the way you're
speaking to me
and I really don't care for the way your
company left me in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere with your keys oh God
and I really didn't care to walk down a
highway and across a Runway to get back
here to have you smile at my
face
car
[Laughter]
may I see your rental agreement
threw it away
oh boy
oh boy
oh that's on you man you should have
thrown away
yeah where you going Chicago
yes
are you gonna help me are you gonna
stand there like a slab of meat with
mittens
[Applause]
thank you
what are you doing I almost pressed your
head like a melon the hell get your car
out of here yeah just just a minute okay
get it out of here
what is your problem you insensitive
[ __ ]
now I'll move my car but I want you to
help him up no my pleasure
oh my God
this Dell got a working vehicle are you
all right
I've never seen a guy get picked up by
his testicles before
how am I supposed to go with the flow
with a rental car agency leaves me on a
Hundred Acre parking lot with keys to a
car that isn't there and then I have to
hike three miles back to find out they
don't have any more cars
I love what they're doing with his voice
foreign
[Music]
I'm really rooting for everything that
goes smoothly what would make me happy
is if you give your mouth a rest
my pleasure like a little silence no
problem thank you very much you're
welcome
foreign
oh my God how can you break a car seat
it's impossible 20 minutes impossible
you want to drive no I don't why did you
do this
no
well this is really comfortable
putting my wallet in the glove
compartment don't let me forget it all
right
I'm worried something's gonna happen as
well
oh my God pay attention to the roads
come on
[Music]
I'll just pull over for one second
just pull over for one second
[Music]
Christ
[Music]
so bad just wake up Neil
[Applause]
are you all right
yes I'm fine yes I'm
yes I will
[Music]
holy [ __ ] oh my God I can't believe this
is happening
I cannot lose so insane
no they're going the wrong way how about
he know where we're going
yeah how would he know
thank you thanks a lot
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh no
that was a great bit
wow
[Laughter]
I mean that was close we can laugh about
it now we're all right
[Laughter]
foreign
ERS Club card
wound up in my wallet
you stole it not exactly you don't know
and then you burned it up did not I
found it
why would I put it there
kindness
give it back I can't
why not because
why because when we start the gas up I
put the card back in your wallet
oh my God
how will they survive are you mad at me
42.50
[Laughter]
how about
Seventeen dollars
I can't do that
please
Seventeen dollars and a hell of a nice
watch I don't have the 42.50
I have two dollars
and uh and a Casio
I don't know what a Casio is
I'm gonna have to say good night so
oh that room has two beds I am without a
doubt
biggest pain in the butt that ever came
down my Pike I meet someone who's
company I really enjoy
I go overboard I smother the poor soul
cause I'm more trouble than he has a
right to
oh that's sad
I wish you were here with me right now
one time I did I get hooked up with this
guy
oh
Where Have You Been you've been in Italy
you had Amaretto amaretto and this is a
gin legit
give me that is there a tequila there
can actually Bond
Jamaica man go to Jamaica have some rum
man dig it irie irie man
oh [ __ ]
happened to Marie
All I'm gonna have around here to prove
that I was here with some shower curtain
rings that didn't fall down
at the very least the absolute minimum
got a woman you love to grow old with
right she's dead isn't she
well I'll tell you
as much trouble as I've had on this
little journey I'm sure one day I'm
gonna look back and laugh
you think so
I'm laughing already
I'm gonna have those griddle marks on my
ass
potato chips
they're everywhere
oh I hope he spends Thanksgiving with
them
go to bed all right okay
yeah here we go
you gotta be kidding me get out of there
just go leave
huh
here's survivors now people
[ __ ] happens
[Music]
no please please please
Jesus Christ is the worst trip ever
the hell are you driving here we got a
small fire last night but we caught it
in the nick of time
do you feel this vehicle is safe for
highway travel
yes I do yes I really do I I believe
that I know it's
you got no outside mirror no we lost
that you have no function engages no not
a one
foreign
car
I'm gonna be unable to get my friend
here home in time for his Thanksgiving
dinner
Jesus
it never ends
this is just gonna end with him dying
isn't it
about people riding up in his cab
[Music]
you should just quit your job Neil
never leave your family behind this is a
life-changing trip in every regard
it's been a hell of a trip
but uh
after all this hadn't done you
you did get me home and I really
appreciate it hey next time let's go
first class all right oh God I hope
there isn't it next time I know what you
mean
no they became friends in the end I'm
sorry if I caused you any trouble oh no
you didn't cause me any trouble you got
me home I'm a little wiser too so
me too
happy holidays
oh
get on the train
oh he's like a little laugh about it
I like I like me
my wife likes me
put it together
Dell what are you doing here I don't
have a home
Murray's been dead for eight years
oh
[Laughter]
this is we've gave a lot more touching
than I thought it would be
I won't stay long or anything maybe I'll
just come and say Hi and then I'll be on
my way all right just come on
[Music]
ah they're all out the door
I can't be a friend of mine
[Music]
yeah so serious
that must have been terrifying back then
when you don't have a cell phone and
[ __ ]
no internet
I am appreciative for today's technology
Ted Misty either
that was sweet that was really sweet
I
ah that'd be a lot more touching than I
expected it to be
chit chat about it all right guys I
can't really talk for too long
um I'm running late for dinner and I
also got to pick up the misses from the
airport but uh yeah I mean for uh a film
from like many decades ago
that was really enjoyable that was
really really enjoyable like it starts
off just kind of mad cap with these
outlandish scenarios like it first I
like movies at Escalade and really build
into its absurdity because it does start
off on a for the most part a pretty
relatable realistic uh you know
scenarios of running late to try to
catch a flight and it's like immediately
everything just starts going wrong right
away and I reference the safety Brothers
early on and uh not sure if it's in the
reaction highlights cut or not but if it
is I did do it and yeah those are movies
like uncut gems and and Good Times which
are very much like paranoia driven
rushing around and uh everyone what can
go wrong will go wrong types of films
and this was that but without a you know
a a massive dramatic undertone that
feels like really dark and hypnotic this
was something that managed to be that
buddy comedy movie you know uh the the
classic Duo of sorts with someone with
the sincere earnestness of someone like
John Candy who's good at playing this
kind of character who's just like [ __ ]
out of luck all the time they're both
two types of versions of characters who
just got really bad luck and one with
Steve Martin being that guy who has that
cynical type of mentality or a bit of a
more of a pessimist I would say
where you know like he's the one I
personally I'm more like I'd be more him
for sure in the scenario and I feel like
more people might be that way because
John Candy's the kind of guy where I
like the reveal of what they do with
this character with the Marie uh wife
being passed away because that part of
his performance dictates so much about
his character throughout you know of
this this guy who has had loss and has
experience dark times and is
trying his just just tries to maintain a
a an optimistic attitude because there
is a there is a sadness to his character
you know and that that kind of resonates
throughout his entire performance but
it's not it's really easy to go too much
gravitas in a performance like that
where the drama of the performance can
weigh down the comedy it was it was a
good pitch and I thought that Steve
Martin was uh great as well like their
chemistry together is dynamite it is
fantastic chemistry and like I said I
didn't know anything about this movie
before watching it I've never seen a
clip I've never seen in really much of
an image other than posters I've seen
before so I was very unfamiliar with it
and sometimes when I go back and I watch
some of these films it it can feel dated
and other than aesthetic wise and then
being aware that this is in the 80s so
there's some technological limitations
on things it I thought it personally I
thought it held up up really well like
it I don't have a Nostalgia for it but
it
I was really touched I was really
engrossed in it throughout and it never
got too zany for me too early on like it
never got annoying because as you Dylan
Baker's that guy I couldn't remember it
in the reaction I just remembered his
name but yeah when the guy picks him up
in the truck and I was like what's his
name Dr Connors and and uh in Spider-Man
and he's in trick-or-treat Dylan Baker
my God I don't know why that just popped
into my head right now but yeah no Faker
like having some more of these
outlandish uh wacky kind of characters
show up where you do get cameos that do
provide good service to the scene and I
found myself like weirdly questioning if
I was in these shoes how how Furious
would I would have gone into a rage
point I imagine much earlier even though
this is not going for like pure realism
I would have gotten to that rage Point
much earlier and I think what Steve
Martin does really well here because he
does have that like anger percolating
with that it's like simmering slowly
like festering within until he does on
Lucian a great scene with all those
f-bombs so he's just like starts losing
it you know because I I was kind of
surprised when I saw like nudity in the
taxi cab was like oh is this like an
R-rated film because for some reason it
wasn't the impression that I was
watching like a PG comedy but there's
definitely an R rating especially with
all those f-bombs right it's got to be
an R rating because you could see a
version of and I appreciate the choice
like that yeah it's definitely are I I
appreciate the choice like that of you
know this is the kind of movie that
probably could have gotten more
audiences if they did go PG-13 or PG
but there's just because there's only a
couple of moments where if you cut it
out of the movie you easily would have
gotten a PG-13 or PG but that commitment
to certain moments especially that
F-bomb scene where Steve Martin is
losing it on the rental uh car side of
things that was so really like that she
just wouldn't work without all those
f-bombs it's it's a great demonstration
of where that character's at the point
and it just really hits so strong for
the comedy that
it's it's just kind of wild to me to
know that oh you know you cut out just a
couple of things you could have gone on
that PG-13 rating to appeal to a much
bigger audience at the time of its
release so I actually kind of really
respect them for going for the R rating
when they could have easily avoided it
and I thought it was funny it was funny
it was heartwarming and what I was
getting at with the characters of of
Steve Martin's Neil is that as much of a
pessimist as he is in his difficult as
it can be to like put yourself in the
shoes of man I I don't know if if I was
Neil if I could ever warm up to a guy
like Dell
I thought the writing of it was smart
for him to kind of lose it a little bit
early on in the hotel room in the movie
as opposed to like building to like 45
minutes in it happens like within 20
minutes of the film for it to build to
that point and then uh for that moment
of vulnerability for uh dell in the
hotel that sticks with Neil throughout
the remainder of the film like there's
always that that that side of him that
sees the child within him and is you
know he gets he gets annoyed he gets
really he gets really frustrated and and
these situations get the best of him
even slugs him at one point in the
stomach
but there is that thing in life where
when everything just starts going wrong
when everything is just kind of
collapsing and it's it's met with
anxiety and frustrations sometimes you
just get to the point where you're like
now I'm just laughing about it because
it's like one more like of course of
course
and I thought that they did a great job
of them especially for Neil
uh for him to come around to Dell as
that's slowly happening throughout the
movie like they you have to kind of keep
planting that seed and and little
sprinkles throughout and they did it in
ways that never felt forced or that
seemed like obvious scripted moments
like by the time they get to that part
in the hotel where they are truly
bonding with each other and truly
laughing about some [ __ ]
I really bought it like there's it it
there's that's something that can easily
be overlooked because yeah it's
predictable that of course that's where
they're bound to go of course they're
bound to go there with the characters
but there's ways where the tropes can
feel very obvious and feel incredibly
calculated and scripted in ways that the
audience can be more aware of and I
thought the way they handled them coming
around to being friends and
was handled so nicely and I don't say
that a lot about these because of course
you got a lot of those buddy comedies
where you got the straight man and then
you have uh the more absurdist kind of
character
and where like John Candy would be the
more absurdist type of character
who is Peter Griffin in Spider-Man
because there's Parts when I was getting
like Peter Griffin Vibes is Peter
Griffin inspired by him but anyway
regardless of that I I really respected
it like I was more impressed with this
film than I thought I would be like I've
always heard of playing strands and
Automobiles but I'd never
I never really thought much of wanted I
never really had much of a desire really
like it's been on my list for a few
months I was like yeah I'll get around
to it and I'm glad I did because I can
see why this is a great holiday movie
and it's a mature one at that like it's
a mature one for the most part and it's
a great holiday movie that also doesn't
like Hammer at home too much with it
doesn't go the route of like I quit my
job I'm here with my family you know but
they do have that with Neil where he is
he is realizing like he spends too much
time away from home and he wants to be
there with his family more often and for
that friendship to happen where he does
ultimately bring him home like things
that happened in this movie plot Point
wise would just register as total cliche
and perhaps it was just considered a
cliche back then but to me the the way
they executed it here the Journey of how
you get to these plot points was was
fluid and yes it's the comedy is is
really well done like by the time they
get on the free like you do start
getting buying into they there was a
right level that John Hughes has to find
with directing it of you when you're
going this absurd and it's something
that starts off like already chaotic and
there's Mayhem at the very beginning of
the film
you have to escalate and you have to
keep going and going and going and going
and it could get to the point where it
becomes like too much and not believable
but it never got to that point where it
stopped being believable even when it
got like crazy and and doing things that
felt a little bit more cartoonish like
on the freeway moment where they're
turning into skeletons and he sees him
as the devil hilarious ass sketch it and
I thought it was great it was it was
great and yeah like I said it just it
never bordered too far never crossed
that line into a point of feeling
unbelievable to the point where you do
have such a tender type of ending that
you really do feel like I was getting
teary-eyed at that I did find it very
emotional and it is a big part of the
Family theme so yeah I thought it was
hilarious I think their chemistry was
great and uh I bought into a lot of the
anxiety situations and it like it was
frustrating but you're supposed to be
kind of frustrated by it you're you're
frustrated with the characters and at
times you're laughing at them it was I
was I was
I was surprised because I'll be honest
with you guys you know sometimes we
watch like comedies uh I'll go back and
watch comedies of of like earlier years
and uh I'm like yeah I'm sure maybe at
the time it was like hilarious and great
and whatever uh but uh it's not really
for me but this this was for me this was
uh I I really liked it a lot I couldn't
even say I love it I I kind of I kind of
loved the movie yeah it was it was a
great time so thank you guys for being
here I had a wonderful time what do you
guys think about Planes Trains and
Automobiles please keep recommending
movies my way I got a list of like 50
movies slowly making my way through them
you know most I can get up like two a
week or something like that but this has
been a really enjoyable experience hope
you guys have a happy holidays uh check
us on patreon support means a lot I'll
talk with you all soon
[Music]